ich habe heute nachmittag zusammen mit
den regierungschefs und regierungschefin
der bundesländer über die deutsche
impfkampagne gegen das corona virus
beraten
wir hatten diese telefonkonferenz ja
eigentlich schon für mittwoch verabredet
mussten sie aber verlegen um die
entscheidung der ema zur weiteren
nutzung des astra zeneca impfstoffs
abzuwarten und sie bei unseren heutigen
beratungen auch wirklich berücksichtigen
zu können
nach der gestrigen entscheidung der
europäischen medizin agentur hatten wir
dann heute die notwendige klarheit und
konnten loslegen
es ging darum die nächste phase unserer
impfkampagne ab april zu planen und mit
den aktuell drei zur verfügung stehenden
impfstoffen astrazeneca bei montech und
moderner und in einigen wochen dann auch
mit johnson & johnson dem vierten
impfstoff haben wir ja eine gute
grundlage das ziel unserer heutigen
beratung war klar wir wollen und ab
april können wir das auch schneller und
flexibler werden
wir wollen dass auch hier die
sprichwörtliche und im übrigen auch
bewährte deutsche gründlichkeit um mehr
deutsche flexibilität ergänzt wird
wir wollen erreichen dass wir ab dem
zweiten quartal so schnell wie möglich
so flexibel wie möglich mit dem impfen
in deutschland vorankommen
die devise lautet impfen impfen
und deshalb haben wir heute ein konzept
vereinbart mit dem neben den so
wichtigen impfzentren und die ärzte
sanitäter und logistischen mitarbeiter
dort leisten wirklich großartiges neben
denen wollen wir immer mehr auch die
niedergelassenen ärzte an den impfungen
beteiligen
dabei geht es uns nicht um entweder oder
sondern um sowohl als auch und deshalb
haben wir intensiv darüber beraten wie
wir beides impfzentren und arztpraxen
schnellstmöglich kombinieren und
euro gratis arbeiten können also
kombinieren auf der einen seite und
unbürokratisch vorangehen und zu keiner
sekunde natürlich aus dem auge verlieren
dass wir denen die unseren ganz
besonderen schutz brauchen auch
weiterhin diesen ganz besonderen schutz
geben und auf dieser grundlage haben wir
folgendes beschlossen dabei war
die empfehlung der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz von vor
wenigen tagen auch leitfaden wir haben
beschlossen dass die etablierten
strukturen der impfzentren und mobilen
im teams weiterhin natürlich benötigt
werden und mit einem sockel von
mindestens oder wöchentlich 22 5
millionen dosen beliefert werden das ist
also der socke den die impfzentren
verlässlich bekommen
die aufteilung dieser impfstoffe erfolgt
weiterhin gemäß bevölkerungsanteil und
die menge der pro woche verfügbaren
impfstoffe die die wöchentliche
lieferung an die impfzentren der länder
übersteigt wird ab der 14
kalenderwoche das ist also die woche
nach ostern gemäss bevölkerungsanteil
der länder an die arztpraxen
ausgeliefert und dort routinemäßig
verimpft es geht um die hausarztpraxen
und für die impfungen in arztpraxen gilt
die priorisierung gemäß der groner
impfverordnung ebenfalls als grundlage
sie kann aber flexibel an gesendet
werden die fakten sind zu beginn
aufgefordert natürlich vor allen dingen
im mobile patientinnen und patienten in
eigenen häuslichkeit sowie personen mit
vorerkrankungen die mit einem hohen
risiko behaftet sind natürlich zuerst zu
impfen
und wir müssen darauf hinweisen wir
wollen ja schnell in diesen übergang zu
den arztpraxen das bedeutet aber auch
dass die lieferung bei der großen zeit
von hausarztpraxen nämlich etwa 50.000
am anfang noch pro praxis recht gering
sein werden also etwa 20 impfdosen pro
praxis das heißt also das wird sich erst
langsam aufbauen aber wir glauben dass
es wichtig ist jetzt anzufangen
die gesundheitsminister und das begrüßen
wir ausdrücklich haben festgelegt dass
der dokumentationsaufwand so gering wie
möglich gehalten werden soll
einzelne länder können gegenüber dem
bundesministerium für gesundheit bis
montag eine opt out erklärung abgeben
das würde dann bedeuten dass die
apotheken dieses landes
nicht vom pharmazeutischen großhandel
beliefert werden
aber ich kann ihnen jetzt schon sagen
dass die übergroße mehrheit der länder
auf jeden fall mit dem beschluss den wir
heute gefasst hat also den übergang auch
zusätzlich zu den impfzentren zu den
arztpraxen mitgehen wird sodann haben
wir uns noch mit einem zweiten phänomen
befasst und das ist die tatsache dass
wir eine zusätzliche lieferung bekommen
von der europäischen union bei und
eckpfeiler kann im erst ende des ersten
quartals noch einmal 4 millionen für
europa mehr liefern als eigentlich
veranschlagt waren und die kommission
hatte er schon darauf hingewiesen dass
hier vor allen dingen grenznahe regionen
und regionen mit besonderen mutationen
speziell berücksichtigt werden sollen
dann haben wir in der diskussion der
länder natürlich auch herausgearbeitet
dass eigentlich jedes bundesland auch
seinen hot spot hat aber wir haben uns
auf folgendes einigen können dafür bin
ich sehr dankbar
es werden angesichts der
südafrikanischen mutationen die vor
allen dingen aus frankreich aus der
region mosel kommen und wegen des sehr
hohen pendler aufkommens von pendlern
die inländischen und auch rainer
technischen betrieben arbeiten werden
dem saarland 80.000 zusätzliche dosen
und rheinland-pfalz 20.000 zusätzliche
dosen bereitgestellt und wir
berücksichtigen diejenigen der einen
sehr starken pendler bezug zu der
tschechischen republik haben
das sind die länder bayern sachsen und
thüringen wo bayern und sachsen jeweils
100000 dosen zusätzlich bekommen und
30.000 dosen dann nach thüringen gehen
wir werden die restlichen dosen zu den
580.000 losen die insgesamt zur
verfügung stehen dann in die erste
lieferung an die arztpraxen mit
einfließen lassen so dass wir dann für
die arztpraxen zu beginn etwa eine
million dosen haben und daraus ergibt
sich dann eben auch die durchschnitte
dosis pro arztpraxis von etwa 20
von etwa 20 dosen pro woche die angaben
sind immer pro woche was jetzt die
arztpraxen angelangt mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren